hello
in this video we'll talk about
necroptosis
which is a method of
cellular death
when we hear the term necroptosis two
things come in our mind first of all
necrosis
and apoptosis
both necrosis and apoptosis are ways of
cellular death
and necrotosis is a hybrid of these two
necroptosis is regulated
necrosis mediated by several death
receptors
so here are some key features of
necroptosis
unlike necrosis necroptosis is highly
regulated program cell death
unlike apoptosis necroptosis does not
involve caspase activation
but there are a lot of similarities with
necrosis like loss of atp swelling of
the cell generation of the ross and
ultimately leakage of the lysosomal
enzymes
but at this point we should understand
why cell
need different ways to die because
apoptosis is already a program format of
cellular depth
then why do cell need another program
death pathway
gasps activation is a hallmark of
apoptosis but we have to remember that
caspase activation is not seen in case
of necroptosis
when it comes to apoptosis it is
involved in several developmental
pathway because it has been seen that
several mutations in the
gasps cascade pathway leads to
developmental defect
whereas several mutations in the
necrophosis pathway didn't show a
dramatic developmental phenotype that
kinds of
point out that these
necrotic pathways might not be useful
for developmental progression
but necroptosis has been implicated in
pathology
such as
acute tissue damages myocardial
infarction stroke or
ischemia reperfusion injury
in case of apoptosis secretion of
cytokine is absent or very less
so
there is no immune activation in case of
apoptosis
whereas in case of necroptosis
inflammatory cytokine release is one of
the hallmark which leads to immune
activation
necroptosis is evolutionary conserved in
the vertebrate fire
and it turns out to be an additional
defense to pathogens let me explain how
there are many pathogen especially
viruses which can infect the cell and it
can block
gas phases so these viruses encode
specific
enzymes that can break gas phases or
they can block gas bases so obviously if
caspases are blocked these cells would
not be killed by the immune system
and that would give a green card to
these viruses to survive in these cells
but in this scenario
necroptosis ensures that cell death
happens so it's kind of like a fail-safe
mechanisms and it also makes it is
another mechanism which protects our
cells
from these kind of viruses
now let us talk about briefly about the
signaling pathway it turns out these
necroptosis pathway can be triggered by
several signaling mediators at receptor
level tlr3 or tlr4 pnf receptor
interferon receptor can trigger this
kind of necrotic signaling
now the downstream signaling molecules
are not well described they are
there are some
molecules which are well described and
characterized
such as
rib k1
and ribcage
iii both of them are kinases which are
involved in several aspects of the
necrophosis pathway
eventually another kinase known as mlk
l3 is
a important player
but whatever is downstream to all of
this is a
certain event such as lower production
of atp
generation of increased ross which can
eventually damage the lipid membrane and
lead to lipid peroxidation
dna damage and eventually leaking of the
lysosomal enzyme and thereby death of
the cell as a whole so in this video we
discussed the overall concept behind
crop ptosis and its implication in
developmental and development and
disease
so if you like this video give it a
quick thumbs up don't forget to support
me on patreon you can also support me on
bimupi app if you're an indian viewer
you can take my unacademic course and
use my code ap10 to get in person
discount don't forget to like share and
subscribe do let me know in the comment
if you have any suggestions or you want
any particular topic to
be
described in a video format so you can
always tell me thank you